hi everyone my name is heinrich and
welcome to another coffee break with
firm learning
i need to admit that today i'm drinking
tea but you know who cares
today's video is going to be a bit
shorter and the main reason for that is
that today i also did a live stream of
almost two hours covering all kinds of
career questions that you had so i'm
very happy because i felt this was quite
a success and a great thing to interact
with you guys this way
thanks to all of you for joining and
asking questions and if you have missed
it for whatever reason
no problem because you can find it on my
channel i uploaded the whole video for
you to see
the video covers all kinds of great
topics i'm talking about mbb consulting
how you get into a consulting firm like
mckinsey bc gilbane how you can enter
other career fields such as industry or
banking what it takes
to get an internship at an mbb
consulting firm and as an intern what
you need to do
to get an offer after your internship so
these are just a couple of topics i
covered
so really check out the video i trust it
is highly interesting and valuable for
many of you out there in this video i'm
talking about how a master degree or an
mba
can really transform your career and why
the gmat is such an
important part of this whole process and
i came up with this video idea really
reflecting on the live stream that i
just did because many people were asking
questions that were
something in the direction like okay i
have this university degree which wasn't
that great my grades weren't that
amazing and while it's an okay job i
feel like i wanna aim much higher i
wanna do an even more ambitious career
maybe
even join an mbb consulting firm but
what are my best
chances to get there if i have only an
undergraduate university degree so far
which maybe wasn't that great
and maybe i have or have not some work
experience which maybe also isn't that
great at least measured against the
standard of an mbb consulting firm or
maybe also an investment bank or a
competitive position within a blue chip
company so as always if you're taking
any value out of this video at all
please hit the like button for the
youtube algorithm and of course
subscribe to this channel as well
for more content on how you can be
successful
in the first years of your career and if
you haven't seen it yet i also have an
instagram channel where i post new
content for you every single day there's
a link to my instagram below in the
video description
and if you just directly want to look it
up my instagram handle is firm learning
as well so how can a master or
especially an mba
help you to transition into the career
that you really want to
if the job that you're currently doing
or the work experience that you're
currently having
is just not what you really want to do
or maybe you're already working in a
specific function maybe in finance for
several years and you're just not sure
how to transition you're not just not
sure
how to move from there into complete the
other role that you want to do and here
yes an mba
can help you because with the mba you
have the opportunity to do that
at a very prestigious program so if you
want to do that and you feel like your
current academic performance maybe in
regard to grades but maybe also the
university itself maybe isn't as great
as you would wish for
here with the mba you have the
opportunity to now aim for a good and
highly prestigious program and if you're
asking yourself well what are the most
prestigious programs what are the best
mba programs out there probably the
financial times global mba ranking is a
good way to start
where they rank the mba programs
according to some well-established
criteria and if you want to learn more
about how the degree in specific can
help you know how to transition careers
either check out my videos specifically
for mbas to have a video that covers
mbas and specific what the learnings are
and whether you should apply for that i
will link the video somewhere above me
so check it out if you have not seen
that yet and of course have a look at
the live stream as well because there
are also talk about many of these things
but let's just assume that an mba or
also a master program really can help
you to make this career transition
especially if you're doing this with one
of the most highly ranked programs out
there but now of course you might ask
yourself well how do i get into these
mba
programs so you maybe know that i did my
mba at insead and now you might ask well
how do i get into insert or into any of
these programs
especially if maybe my academic
performance so far wasn't that amazing
or maybe also the work experience that i
have done so far
wasn't maybe there as probably these top
programs can expect and this is now
where the gmat comes into play and i
know there's lots of controversy around
the gmat many people think that it's
just unnecessary and this is just an
annoyance that you need to do to get
into these programs but i believe the
gmat in many ways is an equalizer and
the reason for that is that a high
gmat score can very much over compensate
many of other drawbacks of your
application profile that you might have
so even if your grades maybe weren't
that great maybe the work experience
that you have
wasn't that impressive if your gmat
score is really high
this can overcompensate many of these
things so it can help you to level the
playing ground for you
to give you a true and real short into
one of the most competitive mba programs
out there so why do these top business
codes put so much end for this on the
gmat and probably the main reason is
that the gmat score the average
gmat score of the class is a quality
signal for the quality of this mba
program so many
mba rankings the average or the mean
gmat score of a class
is a factor in that ranking so if an mba
program has more people with high gmat
scores
this can help them to score high in the
gmat and from the perspective of a
candidate if you don't want to apply for
mba programs and you check out all these
gmail scores and you were able to score
high
of course you'd rather want to be in a
class with lots of other people who
scored high in the gmat as well because
the gmat is a good proxy for how well
you will be able to perform in a
business context and it is also
correlated with future career success
this is exactly how the gmat was set up
why people developed the gmat in the
first place so put lots of preparation
into your gmat to score
as high as possible and if you score
high this can really help you to get
into one of the most selective mba
programs and if you're doing one of
these very prestigious mba programs this
can help you significantly in your
career and then also to do all kinds of
career transitions that you might want
to do but do not get me wrong here of
course i'm very well aware that scoring
high on the gmat is not easy and i made
a whole video about how i prepared for
the gmat the tips and tricks and
strategies that i use to score above 700
on my personal gmat exam
if you haven't seen that yet also i have
it included here in a link
above check it out so yes of course it's
not easy it's not easy to get into the
most selective most prestigious on the a
programs of the world but the point that
i just want to stress is that the gmat
can really help you to overcome
many weaknesses of your profile of the
past with a high gmat of course there's
no guarantee to get into all kinds of
mba programs but it will be a big help
so if you're looking to do that
transition do an mba and try to get an
mba that is
as selective as competitive as possible
in terms of the rankings and to get in
there
do a gmat and try to score as high as
possible to get in this is just a little
reflection on the live stream that i did
earlier because there were many people
asking questions in that direction i
hope this is helpful and insightful to
you please if you liked the video
hit the like button for the youtube
algorithm and also subscribe to this
channel for more content on how you can
be successful
in the first years of your career thanks
to all of you for watching this was
heineken from learning goodbye